hold onto your toilets and dispose of
your panties because we have the latest
creation from acclaimed director bong
joon-ho
yes parasite was the winner of this
year's Palme d'Or at the Cannes Film
Festival so we're gonna take a deep dive
into its cryptic ending and explain some
of the mysteries as we go so join me as
I butcher pronouncing several Korean
names because here we go
although parasite is the story of a
family who slowly manipulates and
exploits another it's really the story
of ki-woo kim although you may think Chi
Tek is the protagonists it's actually
key Wu who goes by his English name
Kevin Kevin is the only character in the
story who changes as the result of the
events at the park home but to
understand this change in how it fits
into the ending we must first look at
the beginning Kevin lives in the
basement with his struggling family who
can't seem to make ends meet they're all
unemployed and have to resort to folding
pizza boxes in order to make a living
it's only when Kevin's friend Minh
arrives that he offers Kevin a job he
tutors a rich family's daughter but has
decided to go study abroad he knows
Kevin could use the money so why doesn't
he take his place it would however
require him lying about his credentials
and he even gets his sister who's good
at design to forge his documents
Kevin accepting this position is what
sparks the story
it's what starts the eventual
destruction of not one but three
families all of whom leech off each
other like parasites albeit in different
ways he's tired of being poor and
concocts a plan to slowly leech off the
parks by hiring each member of his
family no matter what it takes
he first gets his sister an interview
with mrs. Park to be her son's art and
structure which is sister Jessica then
uses to her advantage by telling her her
son has schizophrenia and will need art
therapy in order to overcome the
traumatic episode that happened when he
was in grade one we'll get to that in a
bit the Kim's then upped the stakes by
planting panties in mr. parks car in
order to fire the valet driver a move
which allows Jessica to suggest her
father as the new valet and finally the
most brazen of the plans they physically
endanger the life of the maid by
triggering her allergies to peaches and
passing it off as tuberculosis as you do
each time the Kim family digs deeper
into the park
it only endangers not only themselves
but others they are a parasite that the
longer they dig in
the worse it gets for everyone but the
title the film not only relates to the
Kim family but also to Moon Quang the
maid her husband and even mrs. Park as
in real life parasites come in various
shapes and forms take for example the
Remora fish who leeches off of sharks
providing the shark with valuable
cleaning and smaller parasitic removal
it's a symbiotic relationship just like
the Remora cleans so too does the maid
in return shaves the scraps from the
park family to feed her husband who
lives in the underground bunker beneath
the house a bunker which the parks know
nothing of you see moon was the maid to
the original owner and architect of the
home nam gong a man who built the bunker
in the event of a North Korean nuclear
attack he kept this a secret during the
sale the house leaving moon the only
person to know of its whereabouts
that's how before the parks came she was
able to move her husband a man hunted by
lone collectors into the basement unlike
the Kim's moon and her husband treat the
parks with reverence grateful for what
they had been given in return they treat
them with respect this fact ooh we see
this when Mr Kim learns that the maids
husband has been sending mr. Park
positive messages of thanks through
Morse code whereas moon and her husband
are the more benevolent parasites the
opposite is true of the Kim's
they have no honor and no respect for
the parks they lie cheat and steal their
way to feed off them as much as possible
in fact there's an entire scene where
they're literally feeding off the parks
food and drink the Kim's as parasites
are also encapsulated in the beginning
scene where they are literally fumigated
by the bug exterminators mr. Kim even
saying to leave the window open so they
get free fumigation we have the park
children who by the very nature of them
being dependent on their parents can be
seen as parasites and even mrs. Park
throughout the movie we see her dozing
off like here and here it's only until
later in the film during one of the
strangest scenes we find out why mr.
Park has her dependent on drugs as he
continues to use her she begs for more
drugs mr. Park is a parasite off the
capitalist system reaping millions while
others like the Kim's go poor but
perhaps what is most I wrong
about mr. Park is his monetary gain off
of augmented reality technology mr. Park
runs an AR business called another brick
augmented reality is when you take
elements from the real world and
combined it with the fake virtual one
almost every character in this movie has
both real and fake elements whether it
be the Kim's faking their relationship
to one another or even the maid hiding
her husband at its core the film
explores how far were willing to go to
help those we love with bong joon-ho
arguing that there is a line when things
go too far and crossing that line comes
with a cost
this is personified through mr. Park who
tells mr. Kim that he doesn't like
people who cross the line in this scene
he's referring to one of his workers
delving into his personal life but the
subtext here is what's important Parc
mentions this not only once while he's
in the car being driven home but later
right before the birthday party massacre
one could argue that the theme of
parasite is helping one's family at the
expense of others leads to one's own
destruction which is exactly what
happens in this film about midway
through the film everything goes south
for the Kim's letting the former maid
back into the home begins a series of
events that jeopardizes the Kim's plans
resulting in the maid finding out about
their scheme and threatening to tell the
parks this is the first time we see the
Kim's resort to violence in order to
maintain their sharad with mrs. Kim
kicking moon down the stairs eventually
culminating in her death a death which
Spurs her husband to go full crazy the
Kim's eventually locked moon and her
husband in the bunker but arrived home
to find it completely submerged by the
torrential downpour they have lost
everything
it's here that Kevin finds the scholar
stone almost magically floating in the
water it's this stone that is the
embodiment of Kevin's greed if you
remember in the beginning min gives
Kevin the stone as a gift from his
grandfather and it's supposed to bring
any family who possesses it material
wealth the beginning of his troubles
correlate with the handing over of this
stone so when Kevin sees the stone
floating in the water almost beckoning
him he knows he has to get rid of it he
brings it to the bunker but is attacked
by moons husband and is literally beat
by the rock a metaphorical symbol of his
own greed it makes sense then when he
awakens with a brain condition that
makes
laughs that the irony of it all is the
thing that was supposed to bring him
wealth ended up making him lose
everything he lost when he's injured in
the hospital when being sentenced and
also at his sister's grave sometimes
life is funny like that with moon dead
and her completely mad husband on the
loose he makes his way to the birthday
party where the film reaches its tragic
climax jessica is stabbed by moons
husband wanting revenge for the death of
his wife and parks boy faints at the
sight of this man who he always believed
was a ghost earlier in the film mrs.
Park tells mrs. Kim that when her boy
was in first grade he went down to get
some cake and saw this man not creepy at
all
this traumatic experience caused him to
have a seizure and almost died
this is likely what also happens to the
boy in this scene chaos breaks loose and
mrs. Kim and Moon's husband Duke it out
while Mr Kim tries to save Jessica
Moon's husband is killed by a sausage
sword yes it sounds weird saying that
when mr. Park comes to retrieve the car
keys which are buried under his body in
order to take his son to the hospital
it's here that one of the most
surprising terms of the film takes place
mr. Kim
upon seeing mr. park cover his nose at
the smell of moons husband a man who
probably doesn't smell good being cooped
up downstairs for years stabs and kills
mr. Park in front of everyone this turn
has both a metaphorical and motivated
answer motivated in the sense that bong
joon-ho has set up mr. Kim being
ridiculed for his smell throughout the
film a smell of the lower class when the
Kim's are hiding under the table Park
laments to his wife about the smell of
mr. Kim Park equates it to the smell of
an old radish or a boiled rag mrs. Park
even has to unroll her window to avoid
it Park goes on to say that people who
ride the subway in his mind poor people
have that same smell and to top off this
insult it's done in front of his whole
family mr. Kim is being ridiculed for
the one thing he hates most about
himself the one thing he wants to fix
not his smell but the fact that he's
poor this is why it's so weird for mr.
Kim when he finds moons husband who
looks up to mr. Park with tremendous
respect how can it be so reverent for a
man who doesn't even know who he is in
fact when he says hello mr. Park parks
responses you
Noemie this confluence of emotional
events his daughter being killed mr.
parks reaction eventually make him crack
and stab him to death
but it's perhaps the metaphorical
explanation that is the more interesting
of the two mr. Kim the parasite has fed
all it can off mr. Park the host having
bled him dry needing to find a new host
but it also speaks to the relationship
between labor and capital not to get to
Karl Marx but Kim is the physical
representation of labor that is not
respected by the owning bourgeois
capitalist throughout the film the park
street their servants as objects easily
replaceable within the framework of the
capitalist system in which they operate
and it begs the question in a system
that is exploitative of the working
class is it okay for that class to
exploit the rich even if it is by
immoral means and if you do end up
exploiting it where is the line lying
manipulation violence murder where do
you draw it the final moments of the
film show us the aftermath of the climax
Jessica
mrs. moon and mr. Park have all been
killed with mr. Kim hiding away in the
bunker forced to live out the rest of
his days it's only when Kevin sees the
Morse code of his father communicating
with him that he completes his character
arc he vows that he will be a legitimate
player within the capitalist system go
to school get a job and accumulate
enough wealth to eventually buy the home
so he can free his father this switch to
becoming legitimate also means throwing
away the rock which he puts in a river
we do see Kevin reunited with his father
but did this actually happen is this not
simply a visual representation of how
Kevin thinks his plan will work out if
you remember in the gymnasium scene
Kevin's father tells them that the best
plan in life is no plan because as soon
as you make a plan it never works out
that way if plans never work out what
does this scene say about our ending
will mr. Kim be reunited with his family
or will he be forced to live the rest of
his days beneath the crushing weight of
a multi-million dollar home that is for
you to decide I hope you enjoyed this
video I want to hear about what you
thought about parasite in the comments
below make sure to give the video a
thumbs up and subscribe with the bell on
more things story videos you can also
follow me on twitter at think story
whitey until next time remember daddy
loves you very much